today is the second full day that five
to 11 year olds can get pfizer's covet
vaccine about two million kids that age
have had the virus and experts predict
that these mini doses of the vaccine
will save lives janet chamberlain spoke
with some of the families first in line
for the new shots
okay good job you did it you're all done
daniella wilches celebrated her fifth
birthday by getting vaccinated can you
put your hands up here and say i'm
halfway there
the houston area girl was among
thousands of children to get the covet
shot the first day it was available to
them what made you decide to get the
vaccine for her
we've lost some family members to covet
yesterday and so
this has been really important for us
and she has some medical conditions
which make her
more susceptible parents nationwide say
the same from michigan it's just relief
like it's an extra burden that's kind of
been taken off to georgia it's just a
huge relief sending her back to school
relief is one reaction but a third of
parents in one survey said they'll wait
before vaccinating their child and
almost another third said they won't
vaccinate their children at all
still doctors report there are requests
for the doses
demand has been strong here at texas
children's hospital they currently have
38 000 children signed up for shots
between now and thanksgiving this is one
step closer to a normal life so we're
really excited the cdc says immunizing
five to 11 year olds is expected to
prevent about 600 thousand new cases
from now until march of next year
and for parents who are still cautious
if you compare the risk of covad
compared to other risks that children
face this is a serious problem
and it is a problem for which we now
have a highly effective very safe
preventive measure and that is a vaccine
for cbs mornings janet chamleon houston